hey guys I'm just McDonald it is the
fifth of March and you're watching the
show we call games but news your weekly
titanfall update consists of Vince
Zampella dropping us some more details
on the game voluntarily or not said
details included that titanfall will
have pays DLC as well as free updates
certain beaches that they wanted didn't
make it into the final product so things
like private matches will make an
appearance later without you having to
fork out a extra cash as for the paid
stuff Zampella said they'll be doing a
season pass and not separate
microtransactions there's also a chance
he may have implied that the reddit
leaks about titanfall including zip
lines and heavy turrets had some truth
to them but nothing's been said for sure
that substantial Xbox one update has
started rolling in hot and there is an
awful lot to it the main new feature is
party mode chat as well as new
multiplayer invitation functionality
which you'll be glad to have if you're
planning on picking up titanfall next
week other features included in the
update our twitch streaming support 5.1
dolby digital output and way more
refinements set to make your xbox one
experience better on top of all that
Microsoft hinted that external storage
is likely to be coming in a future
update as well as improvements to
friends notifications if you like to see
a full list of the fixes you can see
them on games but now and be sure let me
know what you think of the changes
lastly owner how much you guys like
hearing about PC versions of console
games and today that talk is noisy Don
over to metal gear solid 5 the phantom
pain the title is already coming to Xbox
one 360 ps4 and ps3 but credited Okajima
has hinted that it could make its way
over to PC as well Kadima told GameSpot
that pc is his background and back
and he didn't want to rely on platforms
to release games commenting on the
phantom pain he said that if people want
it then it certainly will be considered
as for a little history Metal Gear Solid
one and two both got PC ports back in
the day although the third and fourth
installments never did recently the
spin-off metal gear rising revengeance
made its way to PC although it was 11
months after the game launched on other
platforms right now ground zeroes is not
expected to come to PC let me know which
console game you would like to see make
its way over to PC either in that
commenting section down below or you can
do so on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald that is it from me today but if
you join the same time tomorrow I'll
have first day's news all ready to go so
I hope I see you then